this film in IMAX in three words  emotional transcendent breathtaking what  I like about IMAX is is because it's  taking up your entire field of view  you're actually choosing what to look at  it shot it designed so beautifully than  an IMAX that's gonna be pretty Ateneo  there's a tremendous amount of detail  that's gone into this and seeing in the  large format you can really see it  vividly  it'll be an experience that is something  that people will not easily forget to  see this nigh Mattox everything you see  exists together in a delicate balance  with the sound design you feel immersed  in that environment  I think people will be very excited to  hear Beyonce via the I'm in IMAX yeah  there's amazing experience that's gonna  be and I'm accident you must take your  place and the circle of life  you